welcome my name is and today with my
doing specifically means something with
an electro your computer what I am to
you is the science of small comment is
that we create architectures on the chip
that look like pipes although some users
architectures on the chip to be able to
lean on lean tiny scales so in that and
maybe
here you can see a microchip it's made
out of the tear polymer called cDNA
simply dona pass I love saying and then
you can see that it's mounted on a
microscope slide and talk about top of a
microscope objective that's where the
layers coming from a factory and then
those pieces of tubing going into the
micro Finnick device and those are
affecting how we get under under the
device and then use the device to do the
manipulation of the liquids for
chemistry or biology and I think in a
really good way of thinking about this
is to think back to your day that I used
to do biology in biology in 96
please we kind of doing the same idea
but instead of using using a
manipulation so moving to the next slide
this one kind of dollars in the song
that particular station took with my
prophetic collaboration systems and I
picked oh here are the ones that kind of
scene he was a she will throughout my
presentation and the people reference
they're pulling on this like but it's
quietly be able to do our reactions at
hundreds and thousands per second it's
enhanced experiment with these things on
without the chip it's efficient you
transverses we're not going to go into
that in too much detail but the idea
here is that we've got such more volumes
of liquid
my name is III want includes access to
meaningful are presets and I read by
anyone there is this is kind of a really
beautiful
[Music]
but this is the viscosity but it also
takes into account the characteristic
dimension or D Omega predict device this
is normally smallest dimension on your
device and then we know that and we know
that that's fine but we also know that
the characteristics of my critically
perhaps not always
[Music]
balance with what we know about thrill
of mass scale so that graph that you can
see down there is doing a version
experiment if you want what we do is we
built a model I wanted to look at
plastic Imperial base is by n which is
not man one it just flows through it and
virtually measure on different Reynolds
numbers at different residence time and
that's just a proxy plate
how fast and as you can see there are
four lines on that graph relation and
results on characteristic dimensions to
that wrangle Dean Reynolds number of
culture that the literature uses within
a magnetic device ultimately this is
everything from around 100 micrometers
of that interior dimension is we put
which represents and when you can see if
that for the races where you eternal my
amateurs you're really not gaining
advantages associated but conversely on
the other side if you get down to
hundred micrometers and you'll notice
there's a man's kind of range of
finishes then you gain the associate
advantages of the Reynolds number so
this is one example of how it goes and
that's kinda how I came up with a
finished on the slide is a very very
simple training or what am I so I really
so that you can see the direction of
flow and then I'm blown up a section of
the device that we call T Junction it's
a bit things
so this is in the next one you can see
the second image and then be able to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so interesting
then you can support rewriting notes and
lastly forming droplets marriages option
you get your face separation weeping so
the surfactant will allow about that
trouble its page two nos and that's
effectively very override mustard with
some Democratic Senate dressing them
when you don't live that 4-h to me game
so when I was doing this experiment with
changing and what we found is that we
had around 20 but we all get in your
rooms with different concentrations and
different some representative images and
what you can see these beautiful
droplets that image doing on the
previous life so okay medium age that
economy seen in my electronic devices
but why do they happen what's going on
here so we kind of asked them to drop
that thing amaze happening flavor to the
top of this and I around here or where
they happen when the job this was
stationary and in storage and then
underlying physical that was causing
that object to meet in the magnetic
device so at the moment but what we were
looking at here is my system so I have a
dying woman's life or the channel waves
three my critics rocket imagine is
floating around in that system in the
oil and that's a patent molecule is
getting too much thanks to a wall
surfaces
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then we didn't same with the model
alone I know there's only four data
points to us because it was very
intensive to run then you can see that
the same time a steeping group and then
you getting him any kind of lymphatic
and the really interesting that this was
telling us is that the fact that we have
droplets their increase systems in our
challenge muezzin its streaming this
fact on the war and causing
three differently so the first frequency
is two dots two droplets a second we're
going using our device which is really
known and you can see that over time
that nice equal at the top there is a
bit of a dip but it stays in the ground
of 90% routine volumes of atoms new
system so then you can see that as we
increase the tolerance device that is
why we get needs of the pavement so I
wanted to me that if the droplets go
away then it was in fact easy to achieve
these battles collection this is what we
were showing here so if you look at this
like you have basically these sequential
images from top to bottom
no difference des amis bowing and left
to right before the top you have a
device it's new is that each action and
then
[Music]
that training when the moon starts to
happen specifically said that on an
image of the nest and on the right hand
side
yes but Mr Norrell relationship we just
removed the droplet stop the drug that
flowed in our magnetic device then our
system leash that's a monster fashion
concentration shoots back up to 91% and
we call this a device of stepmania we
get back screams orbital mission game
then in the Taiwanese Burman happens
sitting in and repeat this process so
that was really exciting because I
really like and is showing the negative
results to extremely in doing
experiments with behavior use to
understand the fundamentals of our
system and then we use that knowledge to
man the system to get working better
social managers give you jewelry
examples and how they work the story is
[Music]
one of rejection can you really going on
there's that you throw shooting singing
bus and you see in the bottom right of
that life and shape and how much of the
reason was Antonio Lopez and that kinda
gives you a position where the lever
will be hot going on and really it's
communication now as well but that is
the method the traditional method of
forming so what we wanted to do list
with Highland how you can do that device
and undo a battery box very more quickly
but what we also wanted to do was share
that we can make might predict devices
not rpms that first image duration right
at the beginning of my presentation but
using a commercial plastics and they
there is an injection molding but it's
not so many magnetic devices have you
understand bility of this system so we
didn't see and in the pink and blue
image on the left side of the design
device so we have very small features
about about fishing line communis so
they and then at the top that it works
that's when you can really see is
basically and this was a way of cleaning
making this job really preparation which
allows us to get really fast
partitioning on that roller to know more
generally and then we use that nice
thing to convey over there to separate
out the jobless based on radicals that
we have oil and water separately and
really characterizing where that drug is
too much detail about since we wanted to
show that this was a commercially viable
systems and quite a lot of time showing
how this device works so that's the
graph on the left hand side so we're
looking at many different flavors and
looking at how they explain rate well
those various allow us to separate of
these phases and mashing brother top and
then ended early
- boss that were body nourishing the
regime the derivative at which the
separation of miss division and then the
right hand side of this flow we're
comparing as the religion the top the
brush so you can parry this
the traditional method without noting
that it is comparable to to literature
and you can see that when we plotted the
data on experimental graphs and balloons
and we couldn't be detected in the huge
amount so to summarize this section
right now
we compared basically the traditional
method secret shape with what we called
on me to edit data in several different
so the first one was speed of the total
experiments overall this 22 hours
dimension separation and then in our
remaining loop reactor really actively
for 30 minutes all experiments at 30
minutes millimeters which each
experiment in traditional traditional
matters and fluorescence in Iran's new
and unlikely they cost of agents I think
the recent putting the reaction politic
we are extremely low in check and we're
actually do experiments and yourself in
the lab and finding the time secession
doing the experimental different okay so
the next example that I have is to talk
about it digest in kinetics
based on now we're talking about
[Music]
[Music]
that they did and then see how the
digestion happens whether there was a
difference between those might have
structures or the limits when they were
interacting with each other whereas when
they were not interacting with each
other and that's what you can see at the
bottom that's two experiments that so
there's in the talk if you have buying
droplets trapped and low interest
convictions that mimicked gastric and
kind creatively policies and then we can
quantify how these indigestible time and
I know the same experiment in the bottom
where there's only one
and which how these are they just under
get the competitive conditions so the
first thing that we actually did was
regardless of the amount of drug that's
per track you instilled anything for the
mission they wanted to make sure that
the effects that we would see a maybe
but not and not have to actually they
weren't they weren't being accessed by
your gastric or periodic enzymes and
this is nice doing
kyoya experiments a particle originalism
and three experiments and what happens
is you just learning to your device also
arrested many particles and they measure
using sockets all the integrated and
then what the steel is under different
conditions and then you can see that
when y is a achieve targets or six top
that's five track that so the Flavian
dishes are pretty much the same so we
will then confirm any of that property
is to deal with the interaction between
those different droplets so you can see
these data on the next slide and you
know agree to this in too much detail
but what so how did the size of these
exchanged with what is this conditions
that's about the nine job to bottom
ability of the graph and then in the
third little ski area the best years of
the talk to new topics that were
multiple result let's cut wrap and the
bottom line and place is is just there
is a difference in the digestion rate to
physical and we get amazing to kind of
quantify that i'm not shown in the right
hand side and what we found was that if
you wrapped in with each other they are
they just slower and in edges and
to each other and that interesting from
the food is that because it means I'm
finally stood at different rates and
therefore your satiety is different
therefore help to combat obesity but
what I am interested about from this
technique that a lot of research we use
these types of fatty more than you look
fatty chocolates as truck delivery
systems I know look at how we drop this
into that each other but if we stay in
forty percent increase and that's mainly
danger of that water in the troubling
weeks for anything right one minor
example the next way and this is what
was actually working under their system
and I'm adding to this system you see
that creaming system on the top left of
this it's like what's whatever is any
molecules not create yourself more
reduced on memory and what we do because
they don't affinities they have the
water that we say and an employer on the
site itself responds to for monolayers
and I keep bringing them together no
magnetic devices rigid graph to the
right of that day they for mechanical
early structure in the middle which to
learn yourself by name or an artificial
biochemistry and so what happens here is
that then we can do one book with all
available in people of interest and then
this evening and that's what we're
showing on the right hand side that
these experiments they were timely to
see the break-up images and prescient
images that you see there a time that
and transit users through that binary
have created so he nearly done you're
not going to watch three-minute video
about my research
really likes images and video games I
guess with droplets and how we make our
devices and then I just wrap it up for
the last couple of slides so the best
way to visualize microphone X is to
think of a tiny little piece of plastic
around the size of a postage stamp and
imagine on there you can build tiny
little pipes and little chambers think
about like the width of a human hair so
really really small and we use them to
do chemistry or biology on really small
scales what we do is we build artificial
cells on a chip so we are very
interested in the cell membrane the cell
membrane is is kind of the skin of the
saddle it covers the cell and it allows
the cell to communicate with the outside
world and we build these artificial
cells by building the cell membrane on
these chips and using that to look at
how drugs get into cells what I'm really
interested in investigating where there
are artificial cells on a chip is being
able to predict how a new drug behaves
in the human body before we put it into
human beings it takes around 10 to 15
years and around 2.6 billion u.s.
dollars to develop a new drug and a
surprising amount of new drugs fail when
we try and test them in humans there are
a lot of things going on in the cell
this the cell is really complex there's
lots of components there's lots of
proteins there's lots of other chemicals
around and so you can't necessarily tell
what part of the cell your drug is
interacting with so if we can predict
how they're going to interact with human
cells well before we need to do any
testing in humans we might be able to
develop drugs faster and cheaper than we
do so now one of the things that we do
on our microchips is build droplets
okay so droplets are like any drop of
water a raindrop that's a droplet but we
make these on a much much smaller scale
that you can only see under a microscope
we do that on a chip and it really
- so that means thousands of these
droplets per second so then once we've
made these droplets we can add the
molecules that make up a cell membrane
it gives us a huge amount of control
over the chemistry and the biology that
we do what we want to do is build these
artificial cells to be as similar as
possible to real cells but we can
identify and design exactly what
components you want them to have when I
was an undergraduate student it felt
like this was the technology of the
future now as you know phones used to be
these huge pieces of furniture almost
that you would have in your house and
now we've got these tiny mobile phones
in the same way I kind of think that you
know now you're in a chemistry lab and
you would probably use them some
glassware to pour some liquids together
to do a reaction but it's big volumes of
liquid and now we can do that on a chip
with tiny tiny amounts of liquids so at
the moment they're very simple
artificial cells but the idea is that as
we get better at building them and we do
more research in this area we can make
them really similar at least to the cell
membrane to the cell skin of normal
cells but also like to thank my grad
students and when treated regress to
entomology a fantastic work my family
means and thank you also for coming and
viewing this presentation and if you
want to know more about research and the
cool website items and Instagram and
Twitter and the besties all of us and
some more about what we do and life in
my group